[Music]
marching to the beat of their own drum
thousands of people that defied a ban on
public gatherings in the Indian capital
New Delhi they opposed a recently passed
law that grant citizenship to religious
minorities from Afghanistan Pakistan and
Bangladesh but excludes Muslims
I think this law is an existential
threat to the idea of a secular India as
it was defined in the Constitution it
also comes on the back of so many other
you know things the causes of resentment
against the government it's not one
thing it's an accumulated resentment
against this government a government
critics say is using ideological issues
like religion to distract people from
the problems facing the country the real
issue is that economy is on the slowdown
that unemployment it is highest recorded
level in the last 40 years that rural
areas are in distress and in order to
divert attention from those real issues
these non issues are being brought in
people here say they won't let the
government do that chanting slogans
against the government and although
police were told earlier to detain
demonstrators they're just watching from
the sidelines they were even bigger
protests elsewhere from Assam in the
Northeast to salamander South but the
governing BJP insists these are small
sporadic protests being prompted by
political parties look at the protests
today where is the protest you just you
just you just came from gentlemen tell
you know in a city of 1 crore 30 lakh
people if you have 200 people 300 people
and you say that is protest do you think
that's relevant please give me a break
god tele out of by the government has
launched a campaign on social media to
calm the anger in the Muslim community I
really want to show them that there is
really no real grounds for worrying what
is the ground this act does not
discriminate against them India's
Supreme Court is expected to hear the
case next month
but for the government of the land
Ramadi his protests opposed the biggest
challenge since he came to power five
years ago Elizabeth puranam al-jazeera
New Delhi